if there are six people in your family
and each person drinks four fifths of a
gallon of milk each month between what
two whole numbers is the number of
gallons of milk your family will drink
each
month
so let's think about this a little bit
so
i got my milk gallon here for
inspiration
so there's six people in my family or in
your family whoever's family we're
talking about and each of them drink
four fifths of a gallon per month so
we're gonna go six times four-fifths or
four-fifths times six now what is this
going to be equal to well there's
several ways that we could think about
this
one we can express six as a fraction we
could say that this is the same thing as
six over one times four-fifths
times four-fifths and you multiply the
numerators you multiply the denominators
six times four is twenty-four
and one times five is five so
twenty-four-fifths gallons are going to
be drunk every month and this is the
same thing let's see 5 goes into 20
evenly and has a remainder 4. so we
could write this as 20 over 5
plus 4 over 5. let me move over a little
bit so i don't run out of space
plus four over
plus four over five which is the same
thing this is four so this is four
and four-fifths so that's one way to
think about it the other way you could
think of this as four-fifths
times six which is the same thing as
four fifths plus four-fifths
plus four-fifths i think you get the
idea plus four-fifths plus four-fifths
plus four-fifths we took literally six
four-fifths and added them together and
what's this going to be equal to well
it's going to be 4 plus 4 plus 4 plus 4
plus 4 plus 4
over
5. this is how many fifths we have well
this is 6 times 4 or you could say 4
times 6 over 5 which is equal to
24 over 5 which we've already figured
out is four and four fifths so either
way we're going to drink four and four
fifth gallons per month now let's try to
answer the actual question between what
two whole numbers well between four and
five gallons a month four and
four-fifths is right in between four and
five
we got it right